[Music]
thank you
Ursula Kayla Green's Last Story
dragonfly and tales from Earth same
begins on the island of way and
introducing us to this character who's
going to be finding out who she is
throughout the entire story named
dragonfly eventually going to be given
another name by the local witch Rose and
the very first part of the story centers
primarily around this act of naming and
the conversations that she and Rose are
having which continue on into the second
part but it begins with a let's call it
family
tragedy there is this very rich land on
the island of of way called area and
there's a quarrel that we hear about
Between Brothers Over The Inheritance
dividing the them one Heir mismanaged
his estate through greed the other
through foolishness one had a daughter
who married a merchant and tried to run
her estate from the city the others had
a son whose Sons quarreled again red
dividing The Divided Land by the time
that the girl named dragonfly was born
the domain of area though still one of
the loveliest regions of Hill and field
and Meadow was a battleground of feuds
and litigations farmlands went to weeds
Farm stands went unroofed milking sheds
stood unused and Shepherds followed
their flocks over the mountain to better
pastures the old house that had been the
center of the domain was half in Ruins
on its Hill Among The Oaks and the owner
of this is one of four men who called
themselves Master of eria the other
three called him master of old area and
this guy has spent all of his money and
his energy and his youth in engaging in
lawsuits trying to regain the whole of
area unsuccessful and the only thing
that that's good that comes out of this
is his daughter dragonfly
we find out that he'd married a woman
who no one at area knew anything about
she came from another Island and she
never came to area she died in
childbirth along the way when he came
home he had a three-year-old daughter
with him he turned her over to the
housekeeper and forgot about her because
he's continually captivated by his
rancorous revengeful thoughts about the
terrible family that he belongs to and
the lawsuits he should have won and the
guy drinks all the time as well so
dragonfly essentially becomes the
Mistress of the house running everything
eventually making sure things are done
the way that they're supposed to be
growing up rather wild untamed and
largely uneducated and so this is the
context her father is really a foolish
man and when it comes time for her to
get her true name which in Earthsea is
of absolutely Central importance the Old
Vineyard and housekeeper told the master
it was time his daughter had her naming
day they asked if they should send for
the sorcerer over at West pool or with
their own village witch do and then the
master falls into a rage a village Wick
witch a hex hag to give irian's daughter
her true name or a creeping traitor
sorceress servant to those upstart land
Grabbers who stole West pool for my
grandfather and so he's going to forbid
that she be given her true name from
either of these two and a true name has
to come in general from some sort of
magic user so a witch a sorcerer a
wizard somebody along those lines so
this is going to constitute a serious
problem it's analogous to those parents
who because of what's that whatever's
wrong with them don't allow their
children to to grow up to enter into
maturity to move forward into what their
body and soul are Desiring and needing
for them and so
dragonfly is going to go and talk to
Rose she finds her taking care of a you
and they have a little bit of you know
conversation about that and then she
says they said you should give me my
name father fell to raging so that's
that the witch said nothing she knew the
girl was right once the master of eria
said he would or would not allow a thing
he never changed his mind priding
himself on his intransigence sense in
his view only weak men said a thing and
then unset it and here we get into a
very interesting conversation that
reveals some of what we could call the
mechanics of naming in the Earthsea
stories
dragonfly asks Rose why can't I give
myself my own true name and Rose says
Well it can't be done
well why not does it have to be a witch
or a sorcerer what do you do and Rose
says well you need to know something
about the power see and uh you know
dragonfly says well what power in the
Bro says the one
um and then uh dragonfly says well you
said that I had power so why can't I
name myself right and then Rose is going
to make an important distinction
I said you have a strength in you a
great one and you know it too what you
are to do I don't know nor do you that's
to find but there's no such power as to
name yourself and then dragonfly says
well why not what is more you than your
own true name why can't you give
yourself your name and Rose doesn't
really have an answer to that and
eventually you know she's going to sort
of wear her down but there's another
important thing here a name is not just
something assigned to one it is a it is
a gift
so she says my name's myself this is the
the witch true but what's a name then
it's what another calls me if there was
no other only me what would I want a
name for but dragonfly said and stop
caught by the argument after a while she
said
so a name has to be a gift Rose nodded
give me my name Rose the girl said your
dad says not I say to he's the master
here and then she says he can keep me
poor and stupid and worthless
but it can't keep me nameless and so
Rose says
all right we'll do that uh and then
there's a little bit more discussion
about well how do you actually figure
out what the name
ought to be is this a discursive process
of sort of thinking it through
and so um
dragonfly is going to say how do you
know what name to say Rose does the
water tell you and the witch shook her
head I can't tell you her can't didn't
mean won't dragonfly waited it's the
power like I said it comes just so
you're there in the water together you
and the child you take away the child
name people may go on using that name
for a username but it's not her name nor
ever was so she's not a child and for
that moment has no name
then you wait in the water there you
open your mind up like opening the doors
of a house to the wind so it comes your
tongue speaks at the name your breath
makes it you give it to that child the
breath the name you can't think of it
you let it come to you it must come
through you and the water to her it
belongs to that's the power that's the
way it works it's all like that it's not
a thing you do you have to know how to
let it do that's all the Mastery and
then a very interesting observation here
dragonfly says well Mages can do more
than that and Rose who's actually in a
very deferential to these Mages as are
so many witches and sorcerers
uh says nobody can do more than that why
because it's a something else happening
through the seeming doer right the doer
is the Namer but the name is not coming
from the Namer the name is coming to the
child now named into adulthood from this
power which the Namer is merely a
channel for now
what is the name that Rose is going to
give to her in this secret ceremony well
we hear it woman be named in whisper the
witch said you are irian now that
provokes a reaction and not a happy
reaction by any means right dragonfly
spoke in a ragged raging whisper how
could you name me that now why is she so
upset well she tells you you know irian
is from area right she says it isn't
right it isn't my true name uh you did
it wrong it's his name her father's name
he can have it he's so proud of it his
stupid domain his stupid grandfather I
won't have it I don't want it it isn't
me now what's going on there
well part of what she expresses is not
knowing who she is still getting your
name is supposed to be this intimate
gift that tells you who and what you
actually are and in dragonfly now
erian's case she says this isn't my true
name I thought my name would make me be
me I still don't know who I am I'm not
irian
the witch says
it came so
and dragonfly irian actually tells the
witch if you tell it to anyone I'll kill
you and the witch says you're gonna kill
me I don't want to tell anybody that I
named you to begin with right I was
disobeying your father and now you're
you're gonna kill me huh and she says
well I feel this is irian I feel like
you betrayed me
you
did something wrong and the witch says
I spoke your true name it's not what I
thought it would be and I don't feel
easy about it and now here's another
very important
part foreshadowing what else is going on
in the rest of the story there's
something
that's not quite done she says I don't I
don't feel easy about it as if I'd left
something unfinished but it is your name
if it betrays you that's the truth of it
and then Rose does something quite
extraordinary she says
if you feel betrayed and you want to
betray me in response I'm going to make
myself vulnerable to you I'm going to
tell you what my own true name is
at how this and so she gives that to her
and that actually that gesture produces
a kind of reconciliation
here's the description dragonfly put out
her groping hand and met the witch's
hand they put their arms around each
other in a fierce long Embrace then they
hurried on the witch to her Hut near the
village the heiress of area up to the
hill to a ruinous house
so there is also a further conversation
in the second chapter called Ivory and
it's essentially provoked by this guy
Ivory who's not quite a wizard as we're
going to find out but is passing himself
off as if he's practically a wizard
right so there are these continued
conversations about Ivory about Mages
and Rogue and so Rose tells her
the man's a wizard or nearly a rogue
wizard you must not ask him questions
she was more than scandalized she was
frightened now that's an important line
Rose like so many Village witches and
even Sorcerers is deferential to the
Wizards to the men of Rogue to the Mages
who come from this island it's not
merely a matter of social convention
it's also a matter of fear
fear that has been inculcated in them
so what's going on here Rose is going to
caution dragonfly dragonfly is going to
tell Rose in contrast what she's
actually learning from Ivory which has
to do with well how do you actually get
into Rogue what goes on there and Rose
is scared but she also wants to know
what's what's happening there right so
the witch listened unable to resist the
lure of secrets revealed in the
contagion of passionate desire you know
there's these little Revelations and
then go on the witch murmured right so
um
dragonfly says to hear about the great
house is wonderful but I thought the
people would there would be I don't know
and they have this discussion about
power she says of course they're mostly
boys when they go there but I thought
they'd be some of them are really bad
and stupid they get into the school
because they're rich and they study
there just to get richer or to get power
and then Rose says well of course they
do that's what they're there for and
then dragonfly says but Power like you
told me about this isn't the same as
making people that do what you want or
pay you and uh Rose says isn't it if a
word can heal a word can wound if a hand
can kill a hand can cure it's a poor
cart that goes Only One Direction and
then uh dragonfly or irian says but on
roke they learn to use power well not
for harm but for gain and then rose
contrasts that and says everything for
gain some way I'd say people have to
live but what do I know
I make my living doing what I know how
to do but I don't meddle with the great
Arts the perilous crafts like summoning
the dead and then dragonfly says
something very interesting
everything's perilous everything is got
its own danger to it and there's a
contrast here between sort of keeping
her head down just doing your thing that
will keep you safe as opposed to going
out into the wider world where things
are dangerous where you don't know
what's going to happen but you do know
that there's going to be rivalry and
people who don't like you invading as
you might say their their place
Rose watched her it continues she knew
she did not know who erian was or what
she might be a big strong awkward
ignorant innocent angry woman yes
but ever since urian was a child Rose
had seen something more in her something
beyond what she was and when irian
looked away from the world like that she
seemed to enter that place or time or
being Beyond herself utterly Beyond
Rose's knowledge then Rose feared her
and feared for her and then Rose says to
her you take care everything's perilous
right enough and meddling with Wizards
most of all and then this closes uh in a
very interesting way through love
respect and Trust dragonfly would never
disregard a warning from Rose
but she was unable to see Ivory as
perilous she didn't understand him but
the idea of fearing him personally was
not one she could keep in mind she tried
to be respectful but it was impossible
right so she might think that there
could be some Peril on Rogue but not
from this young would-be wizard who she
has encountered and she and Rose are
engaged in discussing
all the things that Ivory is telling
dragonfly slash erian about that so
there's this very interesting
relationship that we see narrated here
on the Isle of way between uh dragonfly
slash Iran and Rose slash at outus about
the nature of names and Magic